Do you just run one campaign at a time?
I would recommend doing that until you get your first deal
or until you get comfortable with the process.
But once you get good at it,
I typically like, I typically am running about five at a time.
So I have, think about this, like once you get good at this,
I've got five niches, five one-pagers, five ads,
five business owners on the hook.
And I'm probably three to five, okay?
Because think about it, you know, let's take two of those.
It's taken a couple extra days for leads to come in.
One of those, it's working perfectly.
The other two, you know, it's kind of sporadic.
So I'm kind of running like, that's when I have a setter.
I'm usually running five at a time.
I can handle five at a time.
You're probably gonna,
I definitely recommend starting with one,
watching it like a hawk.
Once you close the deal and you feel comfortable,
and maybe you can go to two.
I mean, you gotta be careful, you don't waste money,
you don't waste leads.
But once you get good at it, man, the sky is the limit.
That's what's freaking amazing about this, okay?
Cool.